On January 8 a precision bombing strike
lasting almost an hour by Guam based
b---fifty twos was directed against an
area in the Iron Triangle the VC
fastness some 13 kilometers northwest of
Saigon the strike was a prelude to a
combined armed Search and Destroy
mission by elements of the 173rd
Airborne Brigade the 1st Infantry
Division and a Royal Australian regiment
armored personnel carriers attacking at
high speed lead the assault on enemy
bunkers Viet Cong positions are easily
overrun muriatic sniper fire is soon
silent a perimeter of Defense
established and the area secured working
in conjunction with the assault forces
artillery units of the 173rd Airborne
hastily occupied positions a 105 hours
of battery is soon firing on known and
suspected VC concentration this joint
Search and Destroy mission was aimed at
an area near the boundary of hounds yar
and Binh Duong provinces believed to be
the center of DC operation against the
saigon sector of South Vietnam
On January 15 elements of the 1st
Infantry Division began operation
buckskin in an area some six kilometers
south of like a and ten kilometers north
of Saigon Skyraiders bomb the objective
areas in advance of infantry attack and
provide close air support as ground
forces move in for the assault three
days after operation buckskin got
underway these units were filmed on a
sweep through the VC stronghold the main
purpose of the operation was to clear
the area of an estimated battalion of
Vietcong the firepower and shock action
of m48 tanks and armored personnel
carriers are brought to bear against the
enemy this clearing action which ended
with the ceasefire for the Vietnamese
Lunar New Year took place in binh duong
province the area has long been the vce
on Frenchmen
buildings belonging to the Vietcong or
to their collaborators are burned to the
ground during a lull in combat landing
zones are marked by smoke grenades for
resupply helicopters during the five-day
operation resupply and the evacuation of
light casualties were completed largely
by helicopter
On January 18th the US Navy ship general
Nelson Walker dropped anchor three miles
off the coast of Vietnam near the town
of buntao on board where elements of the
25th Infantry tropical lightning
division previously stationed at
Schofield Barracks Hawaii
both teams are assigned and the troops
quickly begin loading aboard LTM for the
short trip to shore
this contingent sailed from Hawaii on
January 4th
other elements of the 25th were deployed
earlier to Vietnam by air
the six LTM that ferried the units
ashore are operated by army personnel of
a transportation company based at Bunco
of village overlooking the entrance to
the Saigon River
as the first LTM near the beach their
ramps are quickly lowered and the
deportation of tropic lightening troops
is well underway personal gear is
carried ashore where the men will
assemble by units for movement to their
staging area general westmoreland
commander of US forces in Vietnam was on
hand to welcome the commander of the
arriving unit and the men of the 25th
prior to their departure from Hawaii
these units have taken part in several
counterinsurgency exercises they are
also highly trained in jungle warfare of
the type they are likely to encounter in
Vietnam local security for the
deportation was provided by Army
elements stationed at buntao as fast as
units debark troops and equipment are
loaded aboard waiting front
the convoy moves out from the beachhead
the trucks will shuttle the men and
their equipment to the buntao airstrip
approximately one mile away at the
airfield the next step in the massive
deployment gets underway personnel of
the 25th offload from the trucks and
move immediately to board waiting c-130
these planes will transport the men and
their personal equipment to the viennois
airfield approximately 45 air miles away
this is the last major link in the chain
of deployment known as Operation green
lights five c-130s each carrying 75
troops worked in relays at 40 minute
intervals to complete this stage of the
movement
next stop is the N law airfield from 14
miles northeast of Saigon from being law
this newest army force in Vietnam were
moved to its staging area nearby other
elements of the 25th division were
deployed in December to the armed k area
some 250 miles northeast of Saigon at
the viennois airfield Deuce and a half
trucks of the first logistics command
moved to the unloading zone
14 days after they departed Hawaii these
units of a tropic lightning division are
nearing their destination the troops
debark from the c-130s and move
immediately to board waiting from
the truck move out for the US Army
staging area approximately five miles
distance at the staging area the troops
offload and moved to unit assembly areas
nearby dear Major General seaman
commander of the 1st infantry division
welcomes the advance elements to Vietnam
tents are pitched as the unit's await
assignment to their base of operations
On January 19th
one day after these elements of the 25th
division departed bung sow their heavy
equipment and support troops arrived at
the port of Saigon
trucks and other heavy equipment were
offloaded from the commercial merchant
vessel that afternoon
the drivers who had accompanied the
truck from Hawaii immediately placed
them in convoy and moved out to join
their units some 12 miles north of
Saigon
shortly before dawn on January 22nd a
terrorist bomb exploded against the
outside wall of this building which is
located in the gia dinh section of
Saigon US casualties were reported as
one killed and one injured the building
which had served as the headquarters and
enlisted billet for an army signal unit
was also damaged extensively the
terrorist charge which was placed
against the building from a small
alleyway outside the u.s. compound also
injured a number of Vietnamese citizens
and damaged Vietnamese homes nearby
adequate and satisfactory spare parts
and replacements are vital to the
effectiveness of any army unit at
Thompson whose airfield documents
received with a helicopter tail rotor
assembly are checked the rotor assembly
is then carefully unpacked from its
shipping container and inspected in a
conflict where operations rely
increasingly upon helicopter support
such essential spare parts must be
available for immediate replacement
in another operation at Thompson Adair
field the wing of a you won a our
aircraft is prepared for replacement
after having been repaired the listing
harness is securely attached to the wing
which will be moved by a wrecker to the
auger fuselage for installation
these maintenance and repair activities
are performed by special transportation
air recovery unit
at headquarters US Air Force command
Pacific located at Hickam Air Force Base
the commander of the 25th infantry major
general way and congratulates Brigadier
General Rumsey on the completion of
Operation blue light that way you got
the operation you got let me
congratulate this wish them well the
c-141 supplied by general Grande's
Command the 61st military airlift wing
is beginning the last logistical flight
in support of operation blue light
during the operation elements of the
25th and Kargil war transporter from
Hickam steel to play cool Vietnam
project helping hand actively got
underway at this Honolulu housing
community known as foster village on
January 22nd the purpose of the project
which was inaugurated by those elements
of the 25th Infantry Division recently
deployed to Southeast Asia is to gather
gifts and needed materials for deprived
citizens of South Vietnam foster village
the first u.s. community to support the
project responded to the appeal by
holding a collection rally competitors
including Boy and Girl Scouts brought
clothes toys seeds small farm implements
and other gifts men of the 21st will
distribute the gifts in turn to needy
Vietnamese under this civic action
program
you